how do you revive a dead Channel and
what are some tactics you can do there
Millie's also grown 180 000 subscribers
over the last 12 months and so what has
she been doing on YouTube so I realized
there's a huge gap in the market there
and so I jumped right onto it and that's
really what helped my channel not
ultimately die what content strategy led
to that or frequency of uploads or any
tactics
this is a no Miss episode of the think
media podcast I'm here with Millie
Adrienne AKA Modern Millie and we're
going to be talking about a lot of
things one how do you revive a dead
Channel and what are some tactics you
can do there Millie's also grown 180 000
subscribers over the last 12 months and
so what has she been doing on YouTube
but she's also an Instagram expert so
how can YouTube creators be using
Instagram to build their brands go
deeper with their community and even
reach new people and so many new little
tweaks and hacks and ultimately how do
you actually set bigger goals and get
away from some of these tactics and be
more strategic so I'm excited for this
episode Modern Millie welcome back to
the podcast thank you for having me it's
great seeing you it's been a year it's
been a year annual social media Mark as
do you social media marketing World
Meetup San Diego and I'm super fired up
to get into this but tell us
um first off you your channel kind of
plateaued yeah your YouTube channel and
so what'd you do and what turn that
around yeah I noticed in October of last
year 2022 that my channel is on a
downward Trend so August September
October everything was going down and I
realized I had to Pivot or else it would
probably continue to do the same so the
first thing that I implemented was
shorts I started just recycling or
repurposing all of my Instagram reels
and tick tocks that were under 60
seconds and started posting them every
single day to YouTube shorts and while
that was scheduled to go on the
background so I did that maybe took me a
day or two to schedule all of them out
for November and December once that I
had that going then I also had to dive
into my Channel's content because
obviously it wasn't sticking with my
audience anymore something needed to
change and I noticed that
the content they used to perform well
for me which was Instagram content the
searches for Instagram overall had been
going down the past few months on
YouTube and the search searches for tick
tock had been going up so I was like
okay there's definitely a potential here
I did my own research and found that
there were not a lot of videos on
YouTube giving Tick Tock tips all of the
tick tock hacks that you would search
for were funny like oh here's a tick
tock hack that you could put your
toothbrush to Daddy you know it wasn't
Tick Tock growth strategy so I realized
there's a huge gap in the market there
and so I jumped right onto it I started
after I niched down Instagram I decided
to Niche out and Implement tips for Tick
Tock YouTube all the things that content
creators want and that's really what
helped my channel not ultimately die got
it got it so your channel was focused on
basically Instagram marketing and how to
grow on Instagram it also you started
noticing that there was sort of a shift
in the wins and started to see where
were things going next it's still
dovetailed into your current skill set
which was vertical video video content
marketing so you kind of went to where
you skated to where the puck was going
not where it was but did you say you
also took your Instagram reels which
would be the same audience your
Instagram reels were like sharing
Instagram tips on YouTube where people
would want to learn about Instagram and
you basically just took your whole back
catalog and uploaded daily shorts yeah I
took my entire back catalog on Instagram
and then my back catalog on Tick Tock
which actually I have I deliver
different content on different platforms
so Instagram teach Instagram people
don't want to learn about Instagram I'll
take a talk so on Tick Tock I mostly
post about Tick Tock tips and YouTube
tips because I don't believe it or not I
don't just love Instagram like I'm my
original first love was YouTube and so
Tick Tock I felt like I was a little bit
more free to talk about those things
because I had already built the
Instagram audience over there and so I
had a bunch of content talking about all
three platforms that totally could be
repurposed onto YouTube shorts and those
are the ones that I pulled from what did
you do because if you embed audio or
certain music or how did you download
your files and did you have any issues
uploading those to YouTube shorts if
music was embedded either from Tick Tock
or somewhere else great question for me
I didn't care about the music like there
were videos that had music in the
background that I uploaded it and it was
like Hey this won't be copyrighted this
won't affect your channel but you won't
be monetized right you won't be
monetized so you just did it anyways who
cares who cares let me throw a bunch of
spaghetti at the wall see what sticks
test all of my content this isn't
content that's like this is gonna go
viral this is I'm gonna test everything
see what works and for after I figure
out what works then I'll create platform
specific content so YouTube short
specific content where then I'll start
focusing on or worrying about the music
and the copyright strikes or things like
that gotcha and what app do you use did
you get them off your phone how did you
download these videos yeah for Instagram
I used snap insta dot app and then for
tick tock I used snaptick dot app and it
removes The Watermark The Watermark
um a hundred and eighty thousand new
subscribers since last time we talked
he went through a plateau there but on a
macro of about 12 months that's very
impressive what content strategy led to
that or frequency of uploads or any
tactics I post once a week every week
and I have been doing that for the past
two years I really think it comes down
to knowing your audience and listening
to your audience so being intentional
with my keyword research I'm able to put
a lot of time into researching my videos
researching the keywords scripting my
videos because I have a team of editors
to free up that time for me so I spend a
lot of time figuring out the topics that
will perform well and also every time a
video goes live on Wednesday I'm paying
attention to the comments and what
people are asking and they're like okay
well what about this I screenshot all
video suggestions and I put it into my
list of video ideas and I use those
comments as video ideas with credit to
those commenters
to really drive my content engine
forward because they're what drives the
entire Channel you know I I used to be
in that stage where I'm like figuring
things out and I have those questions
but because I am now at 200 280 000
subscribers sometimes I can forget about
that initial feeling that initial
Journey those initial questions because
they come so naturally now so I really
need to listen to my audience or else
I'm going to overlook and not really pay
attention to those little things that
really matter
powerful now your keynoting here at
Social Media Marketing World on
Instagram growth and break down a little
bit of what you're going to be sharing a
lot of people focus on the tactics and
I'd love some of those but you're
actually saying that we need to have a
higher level strategy and really set
goals what's kind of your methodology
and thinking here yeah so for Instagram
marketing I feel like a lot of people
have three goals there's three common
goals when it comes to Instagram you
have growth increase engagement or
converting followers to customers
clients sales really and a lot of people
they aren't taking action based on those
specific goals if your goal is growth
yes reels yeah we all everybody says
okay from surreals we know that but if
your goal is increasing engagement you
don't have to post reels right there's
other ways to increase engagements like
dming and getting in the DMS flying the
DMS and I think that that's the most
intimate form of communication that is
the best way to tell the Instagram
algorithm that you're friends with
somebody that you're close with someone
so that's really what's going to get you
ranked higher in their in their feed
their main feed in the story bubbles
it's going to rank you higher so being
very intentional with what you do on
Instagram based on what your goals are
are you ready to start or grow your
YouTube channel do you feel stuck and
need help connecting the dots join this
free web class where you'll learn the
step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com that's
smart and you get to extrapolate that
out to to anything we're all guilty of
falling into chasing views chasing the
dopamine hit of something that just
gives us a lot of reach but it doesn't
necessarily accomplish what are we
setting out for so you didn't encourage
people to say what does winning really
look like what is the ultimate goal what
are you trying to build what is your
business model
and what's interesting though is as you
are going to be sharing on Instagram
here secretly what the audience probably
doesn't know is that Instagram is not
your favorite platform what is your
favorite platform YouTube is my absolute
favorite platform I started on YouTube
back in like 2009 and it's just been my
little little precious baby ever since
and why is that when you compare the two
YouTube versus Instagram why do you like
YouTube better the community of one the
audience and the community of the
creators just feels so different even
the way the platform supports its
creators is completely different for
example I'll give like two three minute
little examples the audience on
Instagram if I post an Instagram update
alert or if I post a video on this is
how you grew on Instagram comments I
hate Instagram Instagram's dead
Instagram sucks now that's the comment
section if I make a video like hey
YouTube new Alert YouTube tips and
tricks comment section hey everybody if
you're reading this you can do it you
know like the community is so different
and same thing with just meeting
creators on YouTube the creators that
I've met on YouTube have become just we
talk all the time and it's funny we talk
all the time in Instagram but like we
talk all the time but we met on YouTube
whereas Instagram creators it felt it
feels more and this is not to say like
everybody's like this but for the few
people that I've met it felt more
collaborative and like oh we're gonna
collab together and get views you know
um so it's just it just feels like a
completely different platform got you
yeah no I love those insights and so
you've been over on both platforms
you've been doing YouTube shorts and
YouTube shorts are very popular right
now what have you been like finding
working with YouTube shorts and you did
one test that may not work for everybody
but something that people could try that
you tested and saw worked with YouTube
shorts what was that yeah when I did my
like 60 days of posting the YouTube
shorts and looked back at the analytics
it looked like for some reason most of
the videos that performed really well
had an emoji in the first like 20
characters and so I just give little
tips is like Hey try to use an emoji if
you notice views aren't working add a
little emoji that makes sense instead of
like three hacks that'll blow your mind
like use the mind-blowing emoji or like
three ways to make money use some money
making emojis that really captures
people's attention I've noticed with the
shorts that I've put out got it and is
there any thought when you structure a
vertical video what is kind of a
template that you have in your mind that
maybe that comes naturally for you or
maybe it's something more official for
filming a video specifically like what's
my mental script that's like the script
yeah what's the mental script I am very
much an educational value pillar and not
everybody watching this is in in the
educational field but I very much start
with a hook a headline if you see it on
I don't know TMZ or Forbes like if that
title is going to hook your attention
that's how I'm gonna say the first thing
to get somebody's attention so like I
said like three three mind-blowing hacks
for succeeding with shorts you know
never never trust Instagram's algorithm
ever again like that's gonna capture
somebody's attention so I say that thing
first I deliver on that promise whatever
I say I'm giving you the goods I'm not
gonna hook you in and let you down I
really want to give you something
valuable and sometimes I'll end with a
call to action but not always sometimes
the call to action is what do you want
to see a video on next it's not always a
sales like go get my freebie sometimes
it is we'll have that sales content but
most of the time it's like what do you
think about this up Instagram update
what are your thoughts on this would you
like to see this video next so something
engaging at the end to get people to
comment and hang out with me in the
comments some valuable tips that we can
apply to all of our videos
um
but a lot of content or a lot of
creators think they need the fanciest
gear and so I'm curious different gear
sometimes also applies to different
content formats but what have you been
experiencing when it comes to a
professional camera versus just using
your phone especially with vertical
video for vertical videos specifically
I've noticed that your phone is King I
noticed when I posted to YouTube shorts
anytime I posted a fancy schmancy
YouTube video where I was using my
professional setup and it was like I
look so cool I look like Sean Campbell
you know like that's so cool those
videos did not perform as well for me as
the ones where I just like whipped my
phone out I had an idea and I just
recorded on my phone and yeah maybe it
was the front camera so it's not the
best quality but it still performed
better for some reason that that organic
authentic approach really just brings
people into that relatable level instead
of somebody watching like whoa her setup
I don't know just based on the analog
analytics for my videos that I posted
when I tested them that was something
that performed well for me wow and have
you experienced the same thing do you
have YouTube videos that are fancy
schmancy think media setup yeah for my
long-form videos if I'm educating I
think people expect the the fancy
schmancy setup especially some of my
topics with Instagram updates alerts
social media trends for 2023 so if I'm
giving something of value I notice my
audience responds best when I'm at my
usual desk setup but if it's not if it's
casual Vlog that setup doesn't matter if
I'm just like if the value that I'm
delivering is entertaining inspirational
sharing a transformation sharing what
I'm going through the setup doesn't
matter so it's really that educational
content people expected the the more
fancy schmancy stuff if someone's
feeling imposter syndrome they look at
someone that like you has 280 pound
subscribers and someone who also you've
loved YouTube for 10 years
and so just thinking about that length
of a head start thinking about the
million things that go through our minds
um you know what are people going to
think what is Sally from high school
going to think she's not even watching
but you know what really Sally I tell
you what you know what is what are my
co-workers like the fear of other
people's opinions and the judgment and
then and then just think about the
uphill battle of starting a channel what
is your advice for people that want to
get started in the Creator economy in
don't start for them start for you I
think this this is something that I
struggle with on Tick Tock right now
actually because it's a whole new
platform so I can relate in that sense
and my biggest hurdle was I I need to be
professional I'm educational speaker so
I need to show up a certain way I have
to deliver this certain thing because
everybody tells me you have to deliver
value and I was so stuck in my head
feeling like I had to be someone or do
something in order to see success but I
just you know I said like if it let me
just show up for me what do I want to
make today even if it's not even Niche
related oh I said it I didn't oh my gosh
I'm not in my Niche right so just create
whatever the heck you want for you even
if it's just picking up your phone do a
little time lapse of you doing the
dishes have a little voice over of you
being like man I hate the dishes and
then post it like it's okay if you don't
have it all figured out yet that'll come
as you post but just start posting for
you instead of anybody else and
everything will powerful advice Millie
you are on Instagram and Tick Tock and
YouTube If people want to follow you
what can they search how can they find
you and anything you want a shout out
that you're working on yeah you can
follow me anywhere my handle is at it's
Modern Millie always starts with the
it's or you can just look up Millie
Adrian and I'm sure I'll pop up on those
three platforms currently I'm in the
process of reapproaching my branding and
my business so instead of just Instagram
strategy we're teaching the whole kitten
caboodle teaching creators how to build
their online presence scale their
platforms and profit off their passions
and doing what they love so that's
really the new approach that I have with
all the content I'm creating on all
three channels so appreciate you so much
thank you for coming on the think media
podcast